You transfer each lead every time.
And in the beginning, yes, the three to five phone calls.
That's the, that's part of the setup that Nick's talks about.
You have to transfer every lead live.
You know, you have to value that lead.
Yep.
I agree.
And, and the thing is, you guys think it'll be a pain to do the live transfers,
but I promise you like B before he was trying to sell the site and he was
sending handfuls and droves of leads.
And then it was wondering why the hell he couldn't close it.
Now he's only has to send three to four leads over a 24 hour period.
And he's locking down $40,000 deals.
It's because he can control the whole process, make sure the
client's answering, make sure the lead is good, make sure the lead answers.
And he can literally like hand just like the Costco sample strategy in the module.
You can literally force feed the, the, the, the quiche into their mouth.
Like they can't walk around the corner and throw it away because you're
doing it, you're handing it off.
Right.